В ефірі випуск новин «heute 19 Uhr» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір.
Ласкаво просимо до перегляду новин.
Поряд зі мною Руді Церне з новинами спорту.
Добрий вечір!
А ось і актуальні теми сьогоднішнього випуску:
Чи вдасться дійти згоди щодо витрат на озброєння?
«Світлофорна» коаліція та Союз CDU/CSU
зважують всі »за» і »проти»
фінансування для Бундесверу сумою понад 100 млрд євро.
Сутички на Храмовій горі в Єрусалимі.
Святкування Дня міста не минуло без заворушень
між палестинцями та ізраїльською поліцією.
Королівський тріумф у Парижі.
«Реал Мадрид» святкує 14-ту перемогу в Лізі чемпіонів.
Хаос під час пропуску вболівальників на матч.
УЄФА проводить розслідування.
У відповідь на вторгнення Росії на територію України
канцлер Німеччини повідомив у лютому про намір
модернізувати Бундесвер та інвестувати 100 млрд євро.
Наразі ще точаться суперечки щодо деталей,
проте Шольц сподівається,
що сьогодні у переговорах із Союзом CDU/CSU
вдасться дійти згоди.
Репортажз Берліну Карла Гінтерляйтнера.
Ведуться дискусії щодо так званого «Спеціального фонду».
Безперечним залишається факт фінансування
сумою 100 млрд євро.
Але як і куди потраплять ці гроші?
Союз CDU/CSU хоче фінансувати виключно Бундесвер.
Проте партія Зелених переконана,
що частину коштів варто виділити
на підсилення захисту від кібератак.
Безпека, зрештою, - це не тільки інвестиції в Бундесвер.
Наприклад, наразі ми надзвичайно вразливі до кібератак.
Кібербезпека відіграє сьогодні важливу роль.
Тому ми й уряд Німеччини переконані,
що ця сфера захисту також потребує фінансування.
Ще поки незрозуміло,
як втілюватиметься один із пунктів НАТО -
інвестування 2% ВВП на оборону.
Для запланованого внесення змін до конституції Німеччини
потрібна більшість, тобто дві третини голосів.
А отже, й підтримка Союзу CDU/CSU.
Але він має чіткі умови.
На нашу думку, 100% коштів варто
інвестувати в Бундесвер.
Це важливо, оскільки нам є що покращувати.
Ці 100 мільярдів євро - не скарбниця
для реалізації усіх побажань і планів,
які хоче здійснити «світлофорна» коаліція.
Партія FDP відкрита до дискусій
щодо шляхів використання 100 млрд євро
і налаштована на позитивні результати
сьогоднішньої дискусії.
Безсумнівно, Бундесвер отримає більшість коштів.
Питання полягає у тому,
чи є також інші сфери,
які сприяють обороноздатності
та які є важливими для безпеки нашої країни.
Про це треба домовлятися.
Наші точки зору не є надто полярними,
тому буде дивно,
якщо ми сьогодні не дійдемо консенсусу.
Тим часом до Міністерства фінансів
прибувають представники партій.
Ймовірно, очікуються тривалі дискусії.
Розмову зі співголовою партії SPD Саскією Ескен
Ви зможете переглянути у випуску «Berlin direkt».
Президент України Зеленський закликає
нарешті офіційно визнати Росію
терористичною державою.
Про це він говоритимезавтра
на спеціальному саміті ЄС.
Вперше з початку війни Зеленський відвідав
зруйновані території Харківської області.
Там він оглянув масштаби руйнування
та подякував українським солдатам.
Швеція та Фінляндія хочуть стати членами НАТО,
але Туреччина проти.
Президент Туреччини Ердоган сьогодні вкотре наголосив:
допоки він на чолі країни,
Туреччина не скаже «так» вступу в НАТО країн,
які підтримують тероризм.
До новин з Єрусалиму:
палестинці щороку вважають провокацією
марш прапорів ізраїльтян
кварталами міста.
Так ізраїльтяни вшановують
завоювання Східного Єрусалиму
під час Шестиденної війни.
На вулиці сьогодні вийшли тисячі ізраїльтян
у супроводі сил безпеки.
Вже напередодні відбулися сутички.
Репортаж Майкла Беверунге.
Марш прапорів курсує через Дамаські ворота
і до мусульманського кварталу до Стіни плачу.
Для ізраїльтян - це демонстрація тріумфу 1967 року,
коли був завойований Східний Єрусалим.
Наразі право Ізраїлю на всю територію Єрусалиму
визнають далеко не всі держави.
Я приїхав до Єрусалиму, щоб підтримати наш народ,
нашу країну та наш прапор.
Ми не маємо на меті провокувати палестинців
маршем прапорів.
Ми сьогодні тут тому, що Єрусалим є частиною
народу Ізраїлю, частиною Ізраїлю.
Проте палестинці переконані в іншому.
Вони вважають провокацією не тільки марш прапорів,
але й приїзд на Храмову гору ультранаціоналістів,
серед яких депутат Ітамар Бен-Гвір.
Євреям дозволено перебувати на території Храмової гори,
але без молитви та політичних демонстрацій.
Вранішні заворушення між євреями та мусульманами
згодом загострилися в районі Старе місто.
Поліція впускає цих божевільних сюди.
Вони приходять, б'ють нас.
Мене вони також побили.
Я зачинив магазин,
але вони його теж пошкодили.
На нас почали плювати, хоч ми нічого не робили.
Це місто їм не належить,
це наше місто і наша країна.
Ситуація дедалі загострюється.
ХАМАС продовжує погрожувати ізраїльтянам терактами
та навіть ракетними ударами.
Напередодні маршу прапорів громадян застерігали,
що подія може призвести до ескалації конфлікту.
У Північному Рейні-Вестфалії формується
«чорно-зелена» коаліція.
Увечері партійна верхівка CDU
та очільники партії Зелених
вирішили розпочати коаліційні переговори.
На попередніх перемовинах партії визначили
конкретні цілі та напрямки спільної роботи.
Каннський кінофестиваль знову продемонстрував
силу кінематографу.
Учора в Каннах відбулася церемонія
нагородження найталановитіших кінематографістів.
«Золоту пальмову гілку» вже вдруге отримав
шведський режисер Рубен Естлунд.
який не приховував свою радість від публіки.
Анна Аренд розповість більше.
Анархія в Каннах.
Цьогоріч «Золоту пальмову гілку» шведському
кінорежисеру Рубену Естлунду
принесла переповнена чорним гумором
сатирична стрічка «Трикутник смутку».
Фільм розповідає історію модельної пари -
чоловіка та жінки, які звикли до гламурного життя.
Вони вирушають у подорож на розкішній яхті,
але в результаті опиняються на безлюдному острові,
на якому звична ієрархія змінюється.
Відповідно, змінюються і стосунки людей,
ставлення один до одного.
Назва стрічки «Трикутник смутку»
символізує так звані «тривожні» зморшки,
що з'являються на міжбрів'ї
і є вкрай небажаними для моделей.
Світ краси і розкоші зображено
через призму гіпертрофованих образів і карикатур.
У фільмі також знялася відома
німецька акторка Айріс Бербен.
Відзнаку за найкращу жіночу роль
отримала іранська акторка Зар Амір-Ебрахімі.
Після того, як Амір-Ебрахімі стала об'єктом наклепницької кампанії,
їй довелося покинути батьківщину.
У Каннах акторку відзначили
за роль у фільмі «Священний павук».
Ця нагорода надзвичайно важлива для мене,
тому я присвячую її усім іранським жінкам.
Сподіваюся, ця пальмова гілка стане
променем надії та джерелом мужності для них.
Премію за найкращу чоловічу роль отримав
південнокорейський актор Сон Кан Хо.
12 днів світового кіноматографу в Каннах позаду.
Ювілейний 75-ий Каннський фестиваль відзначився
неабияким кінематографічним різноманіттям.
Фінал Ліги чемпіонів у Парижі
минув не настільки красиво. Правда, Руді?
На жаль.
105 заарештованих та 238 поранених -
такий сумний підсумок
цьогорічного фіналу Ліги чемпіонів.
«Реал Мадрид» переміг «Ліверпуль» з рахунком 1:0,
це вже 14-а перемога для іспанського клубу.
Однак тріумф іспанців був затьмарений
заворушеннями фанатів перед грою.
Хаос розпочався вже на вході
до стадіону «Стад де Франс».
Збуджені вболівальники намагалися перелізти
через паркан, оминувши чергу,
інші фани лютували, тому що попри наявність
квитків не встигали вчасно увійти до стадіону.
Цьогорічна організація заходу вкрай хаотична,
французи та оргкомітет УЄФА
не впоралися зі своїм завданням.
УЄФА припускає, що причиною хаосу
стало поширення фальшивих квитків.
Міністр внутрішніх справ Франції звинуватив
у Twitter британських вболівальників,
які намагалися проникнути до трибун без квитків,
а також подякував
працівникам служби безпеки за роботу.
Вони вчасно втрутилися, однак,
як стверджують англійські поліцейські,
британські фанати не винні у ситуації, що склалася.
Матч розпочався на 36 хвилин пізніше.
Незважаючи на те, що «ліверпульці»
довго утримували перевагу на полі,
вразити ворота віртуозного Тібо Куртуа
їм так і не вдалося.
Чого не скажеш про «Реал».
Гол Вінісуса Жуніора став єдиним та,
відповідно, переможним для мадридського клубу.
«Реал Мадрид» став переможцем
Ліги чемпіонів учотирнадцяте.
У столиці Іспанії тривають святкування.
Не відстають і ліверпульці.
Мексиканець Серхіо Перес став переможцем
7-го етапу чемпіонату світу
з автоперегонів Формула-1 - Гран-прі Монако.
Через сильну зливу
перегони стартували майже на годину пізніше,
після інспектування дороги автомобілем безпеки.
Мік Шумахер потрапив у аварію, проте,
на щастя, не зазнав суттєвих ушкоджень.
Зрештою, Пересу вдалося обігнати
Карлоса Сайнса та Макса Ферстаппена,
який все ще утримує лідерство
в турнірній таблиці чемпіонату світу.
Александр Зверєв пройшов до чвертьфіналу
Відкритого чемпіонату Франції з тенісу,
обігравши іспанця Бернабе Сапата Міральєса
у 3 сетах з рахунком 7:6, 7:5, 6:3.
За вихід до півфіналу Зверєву доведеться змагатися
або з росіянином Кареном Хачановим,
або з іспанцем Карлосом Алькарасом.
Ось і всі новини спорту на сьогодні.
Дякуємо, Руді.
Лишається дізнатися прогноз погоди.
Погода буде мінливою:
подекуди хмарно, подекуди сонячно.
В Альпах та на північному сході
пройдуть зливи та короткочасні грози.
Між Майном та Дунаєм очікується сонячна погода.
Температура досягатиме від 13° до 21°.
З вівторка щодня поступово теплішатиме.
Проте погода все ж лишатиметься мінливою.
Випуск «heute journal» з Марієттою Сломкою о 21:45.
На цьому ми прощаємося.
Бажаємо вам вдало розпочати новий тиждень
та радимо подивитися «Berlin direkt»
з Шакунталою Банерджі.
Дякую, Барбаро.